the winner of the international
architectural competition for the noble
center is the renowned david
chipperfield architects in berlin their
sophisticated design proposal was
elegant and timeless with an appealing
lightness and openness which was to the
jurors liking totally excited by this
challenge I think you know all projects
are important but this project has
enormous meaning many Nobel Prize
winners are only too happy to influence
young people is the best legacy you can
leave by encouraging discovery and new
thinking and by addressing the major
challenges of our time and our future
the noble center will continue the
legacy of the Nobel Prize basically the
child you grew up with this which is
amazing and then suddenly one day you're
invited to participate it's it's quite
an amazing feeling an architectural
challenge doesn't become doesn't come
much better than